[Music]
well we got an awful lot of polling and
expert analysis this year it's been a
bad year for the experts between covet
and the election results but one of the
things
the [ __ ] class predicted of course was
a disaster for the gop in the house of
representatives republicans are going to
get
absolutely crushed so let's examine very
quickly the gap
between their projections the experts
projections and what actually happened
it looks like republicans will gain
between 5 and ten seats in the house
some are predicting more they also flip
control of two state legislatures
now if you're a democrat that's gotta
lead to some tough questions
maybe identity politics and corporate
economics
isn't a great combination because most
people
hate that they hate that they want the
opposite
they want stability moderate social
conservatism they believe in families
because they have them
and they don't actually think that the
corporate bottom line is the most
important thing in their family maybe a
little bit of economic populism is okay
with them
so possibly the democratic party needs
to stop catering to the women's studies
majors at wesleyan
and start thinking about everyone else
andrew yang
he's been kind of a party man recently
but at his core is a smart guy
raised that possibility last night
here's part of what he said
i had that experience countless times on
the trail don where i
would say hey i'm running for president
to a truck driver retail worker
uh waitress and a diner and they would
say what party and i say democrat
and they would flinch like i'd said
something really negative or i just like
had
like turned another color or something
like that and there's something deeply
wrong
when working-class americans have that
response to a major party that
theoretically is supposed to be fighting
for them
so you have to ask yourself what has the
democratic party been standing for in
their minds and in their minds the
democratic party unfortunately has taken
on this role
of the coastal urban elites who are more
concerned about policing various
cultural issues than improving
their way of life that has been
declining for years
exactly and you'd think they would know
that because they probably take uber
like everybody else
and how many immigrant uber cab drivers
at the very bottom of the gig
economy the democrats created are
listening to fox news on the radio you
ever noticed that
if you haven't then you're not an uber
because they are and those are exactly
the kind of people the democrats claim
they represent but instead they've
ignored
for the past four years and yelled about
russia russia russia
now privately some democrats
know they need to figure this out right
away on a call with other democrats
yesterday abigail spanberger she's an
elected member of congress from virginia
made that clear
i think that we need to be pretty clear
about the fact that tuesday
from a congressional standpoint it was a
failure it was not a success
we lost members who shouldn't have lost
we need to not ever use the word
socialist or socialism
ever again because while people think it
doesn't matter
it does matter and we lost good members
because of that
and if we are classifying tuesday as a
success from a congressional scandal
we are going to get torn apart in 2022.
oh abigail spanberger points out the
truth of course most of the democrats
who lost were more moderate democrats
meaning that sandy cortez who's not only
stupid but radical will have more
control of the party and that's a huge
problem
for democrats spanberger went on to
point out that most voters meaning
people who don't live in gated
communities or have security guards like
nancy pelosi
don't want to quote defund the police
another democrat on the call agreed with
spanberger will the party acknowledge
this